- [Announcer] More than 100 million people
in the US are experiencing
record high temperatures.
Heat waves are creating a
higher demand for electricity
and straining the already
aging US electric grid,
increasing the risk of blackouts.
Here's how renewable energy sources,
like solar, could help maintain
the grid and at what cost.
- A customer-led revolution to solar
and storage is the
ultimate fastest solution
to climate change and to the
grid demands of the future.
- [Announcer] Mary Powell
is the CEO of SunRun,
a company that provides
residential solar services.
- [Mary] Solar on the customer's
rooftop is interconnected
with the grid.
So when the customer's home
and using a lot of energy,
it is by definition
supporting the energy need
that is going on right there.
And when they're not, it is
flowing right onto the grid
as an energy resource to support the grid.
- [Announcer] Solar panels paired
with home batteries can
be even more beneficial
because the excess energy
stored during the day
can be sent back to
the grid in the evening
as solar production goes down.
And this energy storage can also be used
to prevent the power
grid from breaking down
during extreme situations
like a heat wave.
- [Mary] It is stunning
to see this heat wave
that is gripping the United States now.
It can really be the difference
between the grid functioning or not
during some of these
significant climatic events
that create incredible stress on the grid.
- [Announcer] The US
Department of Energy said solar
is the fastest growing clean
energy source in the country
compared to wind, water,
and nuclear power.
But despite its steady growth,
solar power comes with limitations
on how well it can perform
and how much it can
actually support the grid.
- Over time, it will not produce as much
as it did initially.
And so when we work with customers,
what we always build
around is an expected term
of, you know, 25 years.
- [Announcer] Residential
solar panels degrade
on a median rate of 0.5% a year.
A drop in efficiency means
less solar energy traveling
back to the grid to help
out in times of need.
It also means customers
will have to pay more
for their utilities over time,
or pay a steep price to
get the panels replaced.
Temperature can also affect
the panel's efficiency.
Several solar panel providers
state on their websites
that output efficiency decreases
with extreme temperatures.
And even though solar
power is considered a type
of green energy.
- What's really cool is yes,
this energy source requires materials.
It does not require fossil fuels.
- [Announcer] Some
materials used in the panels
such as lead and cadmium can be toxic.
As demand increases,
solar companies are
engineering new technology
to better adapt to extreme
weather conditions.
Rooftop solar is just one
of the many technologies
experts say will be needed
to help support the grid.
- I knew we were never
gonna be able to scale
in time to meet the
demands of climate change
without, you know, the kind of innovation
and technological solutions that come
with a more distributed energy system.
(calm music)